my producers have exploited my Keen
insight into popular culture my hip hop
pop music media Savvy to make me into a
Swifty recently and now it turns out
they're trying to turn me into a
Believer the song that is up is Ghost by
Justin Bieber posted one year ago has
208 million views take it away
[Music]
I miss your touch some nights when I'm
Hollow
[Music]
for the ghost of you I miss you more
than life
[Music]
something
else to me your memory is ecstasy you
can pause it there The View that he's
expressing of grief is a common view
which is I if I can't be close to you
then I'll take the Ghost of You
and I miss you more than life what is
that what does that mean to miss you
more than life he's obviously still
living well no what he's saying is I'm
not really a living I'm sort of I'm just
wallowing in these memories of you in
the past but I'm not living life in the
present because he's not he's not dead
and he's not saying I miss you more than
I love life or I miss you more than I
value life you're saying I miss you more
than I miss life life which I am now
missing and and so this this view is
very common for people when they grieve
but it's not good and it's not healthy
when I'm more in the loss of loved ones
who have died I don't think about the
ghost of them I'm not thinking about
things in the past that are gone that
are frozen in time that are disembodied
Spirits without hope I think of the
future I look forward to Heaven I look
forward to when I will get to be with my
loved ones again and we will all be
together in the light of God himself and
we'll see our maker face to face that
that's that's what I look forward to and
so that is the right way to grieve that
is the right way to mourn ultimately
that's that's where you have to direct
your hope because otherwise you want to
hope you'll just have Despair and you
you will cease to live you'll say I miss
you more than life
I miss you my my draw to my dead
memories of you
overcomes life itself which is very
dangerous and unhealthy keep going
[Music]
thank you
if I could follow
[Music]
to me your memories
[Music]
your memory is ecstasy but no it's not
put a pause there
no it's not Dante makes this point
beautifully I always quite Dante but
he's right about so much one of the
Damned in Hell says that there is no
feeling that is more painful than to
think about good times in the past when
you are in a time of Despair and anguish
that it's not that now you're really sad
but you have these good memories and so
that feels like ecstasy no it actually
feels very very painful when you
remember happy times when you were in a
moment of Sorrow so that doesn't we we
persuade ourselves that that is not the
case and that's why we try to wallow in
the past and and we engage in Nostalgia
which frankly isn't even a real
representation of the past it's history
after a few drinks but we convince
ourselves of that but that that is not
going to make us feel better that makes
us feel much much worse Black Rifle
coffee company is helping you knock out
your Christmas shopping with a ton of
phenomenal new products this year shop
the best Brewing gear thermoses mugs and
apparel designed for folks who love our
country and who love coffee Black Rifle
sources the most exotic roasts from
around the globe all the coffee is
registered here in the U.S by
veteran-led teams of coffee experts
stuff your Christmas stockings with the
latest roasts from America's coffee for
10 off with my code Knowles better yet
sign your Secret Santa up for a coffee
Club subscription imagine the joy of a
pre-scheduled coffee delivery your
favorite roasts when you need them most
it is the gift that keeps on giving
Black Rifle coffee company is veteran
founded and operated they take pride in
serving coffee and culture to people who
love America every purchase you make
with Black Rifle helps support veteran
and first responder causes go to
blackrightfulcoffee.com use promo code
Knowles for 10 off coffee Coffee Gear
apparel or when you sign up for a new
coffee Club subscription that is black
riflecoffee.com promo code Knowles kwles
for 10 percent off
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
modern View
put a pause there so that story seems to
be that Bieber is with his mother you
know their morning his father and to the
scene then they're on the on the beach
and they've got the urn with the ashes
of the father and they throw it into the
ocean it's a very modern view there's a
reason that the church prohibited a
cremation for a very long time which is
I'm not I'm not making any theological
point or saying that if you if you're
cremated you know you're going to burn
in hell or anything like that but
cremation
was prohibited by the church for so long
because it makes a mockery of the
resurrection of the body which is a
tenant of the faith the idea that we die
but death is not the end do these bones
live that actually we will have a
resurrection not only a spiritual
Resurrection but a bodily Resurrection
too and to burn up the body after death
rather than to bury it in a in a tomb or
a crypt or something
is to make a mockery of that and and to
then scatter those Ashes to the wind or
put them into the ocean makes a mockery
of that as well when we expect the
resurrection of the body then then and
and we expect that there will be life
Everlasting we have little markers of
people we say no you were buried here
and here's your headstone and we can go
and we can pray for this person and we
look forward to the day when as was
prefigured at the resurrection of Christ
when the tombs will open and the dead
will walk around again and so that the
same errors of modernity and despair and
wallowing in the past that you see
through described throughout this song
culminates in this final idea of okay
throwing the ashes away it's just a
ghost it's just a memory that we cannot
look forward to again keep on
I
like more than I
was that guy is that like mom's
boyfriend or something or is that the
dad
[Music]
and do we know I couldn't quite tell who
that figure it's not like that was just
the ghost of the dad came back and she
went over with him is it or was that
like a boyfriend or something it's sort
of sort of unclear well if it's a
boyfriend that's kind of a it's kind of
a whatever ending she's like okay well
moving on yeah okay here's the next guy
it's kind of depressing and if it's the
the father is it it could be expressing
the idea that only once we bury our dead
can we really settle you know with
memory of them again and those memories
won't cause us so much pain but that
doesn't seem to be the idea put forward
by the song one because they keep
reminiscing and they keep you know
showing these memories of the of the
dead father uh throughout and then they
never actually bury him they just sort
of scatter his ashes into the wind so
a a somewhat ambiguous ending to a song
that expresses a very modern and popular
but but damaging and false
Hue of of how to mourn and maybe that
was intentional I don't know I think
Bieber is a Christian right he says he's
a Christian I don't know I guess many
self-described Christians take similar
kinds of views of that as well but
ultimately that's not that's not the
thing we don't want soft soap and
sentimentality and looking back and
saying oh the ghost of you is my the
memories are my ecstasy and there you go
I'm going to throw your Ashes to the
wind no we pray in real hope based on
the theological fact and virtue of hope
that that we will see our loved ones
again in heaven and we pray for them and
we hope that all the saints of Heaven
are praying for us and then we'll all be
together before God someday
not just some sappy kind of memories or
anything like that but the real the real
experience of the real thing okay that's
our show I'm Michael Knowles this the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]